ce lundi marque le début de la campagne
officielle pour le référendum sur
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
le deuxième vote en deux ans sur cette
question aura donc lieu le 4 octobre un
référendum qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
du processus de décolonisation de
l'accord de nouméa le 4 novembre 2018
lors du premier scrutin
d'autodétermination est partisan du
maintien de la nouvelle-calédonie dans
la france avait obtenu près 2 56% des
suffrages
si les antilles indépendance m'emporte à
nouveau un troisième référendum peut
être organisé d'ici 2022 et pour en
parler en direct avec nous allemands
bensaïd et anthropologue et spécialiste
de la nouvelle calédonie ce monsieur ben
ça bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors lors du
dernier scrutin est partisan du maintien
de la nouvelle-calédonie dans la france
avait remporté plus de 56%
quelle est selon vous la tendance
aujourd'hui je pense que les résultats
l'avons pas être le radicalement
transformé par le référendum du 4
octobre
par contre durant ces deux années les
indépendantistes dans les élections
provinciales et municipales ont continué
à marquer des points
alors maintenant reste à savoir comment
pourrait se répercuter cette progression
dans le référendum lui-même dans les
résultats du canada mais c'est très
difficile de le prédire en tout état de
cause il y peu probable que les
indépendants qu'ils puissent cette fois
ci l'emporté même s'ils peuvent
améliorer leur score en tout cas en 2018
le score à le score des indépendantistes
étaient certes plus faibles que ceux des
partisans du maintien de la nouvelle
calédonie en france mais leur score
était beaucoup plus fort que prévu
oui le score et qui est beaucoup plus
fort que prévu d'abord parce que gagner
le prix du lait
les sondages étaient pas bien fait et
deuxièmement parce que les
indépendantistes ont su mobiliser très
largement la jeunesse dans les villages
les plus reculés alinéa aussi et c'est
cette mobilisation qui s'est répercutée
et puis c'était un avertissement au nom
d'un des parents pitt ou aux antilles un
départ en piste pour savoir qui devront
toujours compter avec une présence
indépendantiste significative
on ne veut que quand tout cas le non l'a
emporté en 2018 quelles sont les
craintes des opposants à l'indépendance
pourquoi veut-il que la nouvelle
calédonie reste dans la france donc elle
reste dans la france parce que pour eux
c'est plus simple ils vivent dans une
sorte d'extension outre-mer du
dispositif français tandis que les
indépendantistes la majorité mélanie
siens kanak se trouve en province nord
et dans la province des villes provinces
avec laquelle la province sud où ils
n'ont indépendantistes sont majoritaires
et largement dominantes ont ciblé le
lait européens pour d'être l'amant de
nouvelle calédonie pour le sentiment
qu'ils peuvent vivre sans les kanaks et
que la porte de la perpétuer le mode de
fonctionnement sur une économie de type
de comptoir une économie assistée et un
soutien très important de la france dès
qu'il y avait des problèmes financiers
industriel ou économique
s'il devait y avoir une indépendance ça
nécessiterait que ces gens discutent
avec les indépendantistes pour
construire une nouvelle société
c'est ce à quoi les indépendantistes et
notamment le président de la province
nord pool du mti les avis que dès
maintenant mais sans succès alors en cas
de nouvelle victoire du non à troisième
réfère un an pour être organisée indices
2001 2 3 scrutin c'est manifestement ce
qui est prévu dans les accords de nouméa
oui c'est ce qui avait été prévu par
l'équipe de lionel jospin qui a préparé
la corde linea afin de faire mûrir en
quelque sorte cette idée d'indépendance
et de lignes chance puisque tu m'as vous
appelle parie sur l'intelligence d'aller
à laisser une chance à une société
plurielle un dialogue inter
communautaires pour construire une
indépendance en association ou en
partenariat avec la france alors il ya
eu des progrès dans cette direction
notamment dans l'intérieur de la
nouvelle calédonie et eh bien on va voir
si ces progrès vont continuer jusqu'en
2022 s'il ya un référendum en 2022 mais
de toute façon c'est la seule issue en
nouvelle calédonie que celle d'un
dialogue concerté pour construire un
nouveau pays
alban bensa merci pour votre éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes anthropologue et
spécialiste la nouvelle calédonie
mercier